a funny thing happens if you travel
north from January
go far enough and it gets dark in the
middle of the day this is what the brief
winter daylight looks like in northern
Norway that's where I meet up with a
team of researchers bound for the Arctic
Ocean
I mean like condition I'm spending two
weeks with scientists exploring the
Arctic during the polar night the time
of year that brings 24-hour darkness
we're here in the dark to study the
Arctic ecosystem before the ice that
defines it disappears
[Music]
seasons are supercharged in the Arctic
as the Earth orbits the Sun the amount
of light reaching the northern
hemisphere changes you may have noticed
your days shrinking in the winter but
it's way more drastic near the North
Pole where for four months the Sun never
Rises above the horizon and then in the
summer the Sun never sets the sea ice
floating on the Arctic Ocean follows a
similar pattern growing in the fall and
winter and melting in the spring when
the massive spring blooms of algae feed
the ecosystem but alongside those
drastic seasonings scientists have also
detected a long-term trend that's
underway back here on earth new word
that the Arctic sea ice has melted to
near record levels global warming will
leave the Arctic ice free during the
summer within two decades look at where
the sea ice was in the 1980s compared to
the first decade of the 2000s and this
line shows the data from 2018 so far
20 years ago the part of the sea we
explored on the Helmer Hansen would have
been coated with ice three to six feet
and thick open ocean gives you more
direct access to study that ocean to
open up a gateway into the dark polar
lines we visit 22 stations on our
journey
collecting measurements and samples to
gauge the health of the ecosystem before
the light returns in the spring
scientists have mostly ignored the
Arctic winter assuming that life here is
dormant during the dark months but when
they looked closer they found an
ecosystem teeming with life
open up the bedsheets is actually a
reproduction or hanky-panky that is
happening on the seafloor life sunlight
the darkness is actually filled with
both life the mission of this journey is
to track the physical and biological
aspects of the ocean as the ice vanishes
above it water samples from the deep
helped scientists identify currents that
may be changing robotic gliders roam the
sea for months measuring the properties
of water and probing for signs of life
you've probably heard that big arctic
species like polar bears are endangered
by the melting ice but tiny creatures
also rely on it some types of algae
cling to its surface and when they die
they fall to the muddy sea floor
becoming food for mollusks worms and
crustaceans and those creatures are food
for fish seals and walruses stir-crazy
scientists really like walruses other
scientists zap the water with light to
detect algae cells and measure their
response animals called zooplankton just
a few millimeters long come up in the
Nets and the scientists test how they
behave under different light and water
conditions they also document which
species are present and how many as do
the team's studying fish without this
data we won't be able to measure how
less ice and more light will change the
ecosystem so get the baseline they
thought in order to understand how they
are changing and how they will change
quickly shrinking sea ice means more
light reaches the Arctic Ocean in the
spring and fall and that light is
fueling massive new blooms of algae
called phytoplankton that's already
helping several species of whales thrive
in the Arctic but will the extra light
benefit the entire ecosystem in the
future
depends but that is contingent on the
phytoplankton themselves having enough
nutrients to fuel their growth these
nutrients like nitrogen and phosphate
are found naturally in the ocean they
nourish the algae like fertilizer for a
gardening but we don't know whether
their levels will rise along with all
the new sunlight nutrients in the
surface ocean as the light floods in a
separate problem is disruptions and
timing the blooms are coming earlier in
the spring on average but if they appear
too early baby zooplankton that hatch
later could go hungry and fish
populations in turn would diminish as
well the Arctic has undergone massive
changes before things come to life it
will change will change but carbon
pollution is causing Arctic summer
temperatures to rise faster than they
have in 1,500 years it is too soon to
know how severe these disruptions will
be on the ecosystem so scientists will
return to the same stations in the
spring and early summer to monitor a
rapidly changing landscape
thanks for watching saw the next episode
in this three-part series we'll look at
how the Arctic could be affecting
weather across the world
[Music]
you
[Music]